ونتابع هذه الصور للقصف الاسرائيلي العنيف
على شمال قطاع غزه هذه الصور المباشره
للقصف
المستمر على شمال قطاع
غزه
اذا معارك ضاريه على الارض وقصف عنيف كما
نشاهد على هذه الصور التي وصلتنا قبل قليل
ل كما نرى قنابل ضوئيه
وانفجارات
ودخان سحب من الدخان في السماء في سماء
قطاع غزه وانفجارات متواصله واضح ان هذا
القصف يعد من الاعنف الذي تشهده قطاع
يشهده قطاع غزه في شمال القطاع هذا هذه
الصور وصلتنا قبل قليل لهذا القصف
المتواصل
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من مستشفى الشفاه في مدينه
غزه مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل ضعنا
في صوره الوضع الان حيث
انت
صحيح تستمر الغارات الاسرائيليه على
المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه وهذه
منطقه حي الدرج ومنطقتي حي الدرج ومنطقه
الشيخ رضوان هاتين المنطقتين يشهدان قصف
عنيف منذ ساعات طويله وهذه هذا القصف هو
للمره الاولى منذ ايام يكون بهذا العنف
وبهذه القوه وسمع دوي الانفجارات بشكل
ملحوظ في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه
الى وميض هذه الانفجارات وصل الى مستشفى
الشفاء حيث نحن متواجدون بالاضافه الى ذلك
قصفت قوات الاحتلال بوابه مركز الصناعه او
مركز الامم المتحده الواقع في منطقه
الصناعه ووصل الى مستشفى الشفاء ع اصابات
حتى هذه اللحظه وهناك عدد من الشهداء وفق
ما افاد المواطنون في ذاك المكان ولم يصل
الشهداء الى هذا المكان بسبب خطوره الوضع
وصعوبه التنقل ما بين الاماكن هذا الاماك
المكان ياوي عشرات النازحين ولازال هناك
عدد من الشهداء ولا نعرف ما هي هذا القصف
سوى ان قوات الاحتلال تقصف اماكن لواء
النازحين بالاضافه الى ذلك
قامت قوات الاحتلال بقنص العشرات في منطقه
شارع الوحده بالاضافه الى منطقه شارع
الصناعه هاتين المنطقتين التين تتمركز
بهما قوات الاحتلال بشكل ملحوظ وقنص عدد
من الشهداء في ذاك المكان بشكل مباشر حيث
ادى هذا القنص الى الاستشهاد بشكل مباشر
وحصي هذ هؤلاء الشهداء هم 37 شهيدا وصلوا
الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي هذه الحصيله لم
تندرج ولم تتضمن مجزره عائله سام سالم
التي فقت 100 شهيد في مدينه غزه لكن الوضع
يزداد صعوبه وتاز ما في ظل انهيار القطاع
الصحي وسيطره قوات الاحتلال على مستشفى
المعمداني وبقاء مستشفى الشفاء هو النقطه
الوحيده لعلاج المصابين فقط بالاسعافات
الاوليه هناك العشرات هم بحاجه الى عمليات
وبحاجه الى عنايه طبيه فائقه في ظل الوضع
المستمر وبعد قصف قوات الاحتلال لهذه
الحالات بشكل مباشر هناك عدد من الحالات
هي بتور وبحاجه الى وقف نزيف وبحاجه ايضا
الى وحدات دم علما ان وزاره الصحه اليوم
اطلقت نداءات استغاثه للمواطنين
المتواجدين في مدينه غزه بالتبرع في
بوحدات الدم بعد تشغيل المختبر بادنى
الامكانات علما ان الطواقم الطبيه تحاول
تشغيل المختبر منذ ما يقارب اسبوع ولم
تنجح في هذه المحاولات سوى اليوم بالتشغيل
بالحد الادنى لانقاذ حياه المرضى داخل
مجمع الشفاء الطبي بالاضافه الى ذلك الوضع
المعيشي الصعب في داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
ال المواطنون يشتكون من عدم توفر المياه
والاغذيه وعدم دخول المساعدات الى هذه
المنطقه التي تاوي عشرات الاف النازحين في
مختلف المناطق الغربيه ابار المياه قصفت
بفعل قوات الاحتلال بالاضافه الى ذلك دمرت
ولا يوجد حتى ابار متوفره سوى بعض الابار
البسيطه التي يتغذى عليها المواطنون ويصطف
المواطنون ساعات طويله للحصول على جالون
واحد من المياه الوضع المعيشي يزداد تازم
وصعوبه ايضا في ظل البرد القارص على مدينه
غز
شكرا جزيلا لك اسماعيل الغول من شمال قطاع
غزه